[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the distinct honor of sitting
remotely with greg ellis who is an actor
director author he is also i believe
newly a video podcaster has a new series
coming out called the respondent and he
has another podcast
called what is it the voices in my head
the voices in my head i like that title
quite a bit actually
it's a good one thank you so welcome
greg
thank you it's lovely to be here so i'm
not sure exactly where
to start you and i i think are newly
acquainted with each other at least
uh in personal contact we've not met in
person but we have now
had discussions and i find you
fascinating
and uh a very pleasant surprise
that that is such a person exists so
um you obviously are not from around
these parts
no originally i'm from northwest england
a little village called
ainsdale uh by the sea uh close to a
town called southport about 30 minutes
north and 30 minutes west of manchester
and currently reside in los angeles you
reside in los angeles and
um how long have you been in la i've
been here about
uh 25 years now good grief that long
25 years and are you a citizen i am i
became an american citizen around the
time
president obama was running because i
wanted to
be able to give back and i remember
calling my first phone call
on behalf of his campaign was to some
older lady in wichita and she must have
been very surprised when she had
do excuse me do you have a few moments
of your time i'd like to talk to you
about um
barack obama um i always remember that
call i'm very proud to become a u.s
citizen
yes well congratulations uh thanks good
good to have you on board
um just in time for uh this
next round of electoral politics i guess
um
trump era is treating you well i trust
it's interesting times isn't it uh i
remember looking at the um
the debate between uh
hillary clinton and donald trump in 2016
and i was one of the few who
who really believed that he was going to
win
i actually turned the sound off for the
debate and studied their
body language and their facial
expressions and
since then i think there's been this uh
perhaps
many people haven't accepted the fact
that he's one we don't have to be happy
about it
we can be outraged and disgusted and etc
etc but accepting that he's won and
how we can focus on the positives on the
left
to get someone to challenge um
to take the presidency back i think is
more important than orange man bad trump
derangement syndrome
yeah i agree uh once somebody tells me
that
um they have a clear understanding of
what's supposed to happen in this
election i i know that
uh it's about to become a very awkward
conversation i have the sense we have
two candidates who both have an
iron-clad
argument for why they must be elected
and each of them is right each of their
arguments being that the other person
is not fit for the job
yes i agree and it's what you talk about
the lesser lesser evil or the zero-sum
game
you know this it's like a an idea
illogical cold war if you will um i
remember
during the cold war james baker said
it's important that we talk to our
enemies and our friends
and this these limits of absolutism
are morphic and complex
what we sense how we feel and experience
these limits is the epitome i think of
learning on the edge of volatile events
and it does feel like volatile times
often the tyranny of the urgent consumes
us and we
degenerate to to somewhat immature
behavior
and acting out um and
how we approach those limits and meet
them is
asking newer questions and leaving
nuance and doubt
firmly in the forefront i think
i i agree with that i am uh
i'm not sure quite how to ask the
question but
i've done a lot of traveling as i know
you have and that has given me a
different perspective
on on the us than i would have if i had
simply been here and not ventured very
far
i'm certain you have a different
perspective though having
uh join and become a citizen of the us
having been
born abroad what do you think americans
miss about the u.s
when you say what do they miss about the
u.s do you mean
what do they miss because they're
americans
yeah what's um what is in our blind spot
given that uh you know we all are
are shaped by our natal experiences and
um not being able to see the u.s from
the outside i have a sense
is a distortion but it's a little hard
for me to say what the distortion is
because of course i have it too yeah i
think i'm
i may i may be having lived here for 25
years i might not be the perfect person
to ask that question although i am
reminded of being on the tube station
platform the underground
or it's the subway in america many years
ago before i came to america
and it was packed full of the the brits
the
stiff upper lip brits on their way to
work
and this um american fellow this tourist
entered the platform uh walked in and he
had very bright shorts and
very loud t-shirt and
he stood there and after about 10
seconds he said god damn what's wrong
with you bridge you're all just so quiet
and
where you're gonna make it and it made
me shock and i looked around and i could
see
these uh straight-laced brits i'm
probably one of them too
and you could see they were cracking
smiles and they wanted to kind of
you know let their personality out and i
think there is a beautiful part of
america's but i talk a lot about
america's personality and how it's
perceived by
perhaps by different nations around the
world and i think it's in pain right now
and it's somewhat disordered
in terms of the lens of how we view it
um the one thing i find really
perplexing
is the notion that we can't celebrate
uh the best aspects of being american
it seems to be i was talking with an
agent at a big agency the other day
caa here in hollywood and
it sounded like he just detested america
in fact he said that china was
their human rights uh in china and north
korea were better than america the
record oh my god
and and and and to have these extreme
conversations and hold space and listen
with curiosity and not
like where where does that come from you
know where does this hatred of the place
that's given us all we're all immigrants
has given us an amazing opportunity it's
a grand experiment i think
yeah there's something very troubling
about that i uh
i wonder i i would like to
think that that particular myopia is
born
of a positive instinct that maybe the
desire
to understand what we are falling short
on has caused us to over focus and to
maybe
imagine things about the rest of the
world that aren't true but for anyone to
say
with a straight face that our
human rights record is um you know falls
short of china or north korea is to just
evidence a complete
failure of awareness of what is taking
place elsewhere in the world i mean for
all of our faults
we are uh well ahead of those two oh
very much so i you know i rem i'm
reminded of
images from decades ago in the middle
east of the burning of the american flag
and the outrage in america at how that
event was perceived when viewed and
recently seeing
americans burning the american flag
outside the white house
and i think there is reason to be upset
and
angry and to protest and to come
together
uh that level i i
just can't i can't get my head around
that
no it's it's crazy and you know
unfortunately the
sensibilities of the moment actually are
placing the american experiment in
danger
so it's possible that these people who
have this warped view
of of the u.s are going to
get to test their hypothesis and see
what life is like
without it but my
fear is that they're not even honest
enough with themselves to remember
what they thought that at the point that
it becomes clear what they've lost
they will imagine that they were always
on the right side of that
rather than even just honestly tracking
uh their change in viewpoint
yeah i think there comes a point there
does come a point where you have to
given given this cancel culture we've
talked about you and i before brett
you have to kind of plant your flag in
the sand
firmly and say you know what i'm going
to go down on record whether it be
this tweet this uh moment in time and
speak my mind because i think we've
reached this brinking point where
there's a segment of the population on
both sides i think who believe that the
other side's political wrong-headedness
equates to essentially immorality and
how do we solve society's problems if we
don't talk to each other
break virtual bread um you know it's
like
you are you willing to accept that there
are people on the other side of the
political aisle who disagree with you
but nonetheless people of honor or is it
your position that anybody who disagrees
with your political prescription ipso
facto
is dishonorable and
what are we afraid of what are we afraid
of
is it um is it courage
having the courage to speak up fear of
being cancelled losing our livelihood
you know it's like it's like we have
this circular choir preaching to each
other
to to a degree well i think actually you
ask
what is it that we're afraid of and i'm
concerned that it's actually
a different process that causes people
to have that
that caricature view that this is
actually something human beings are
wired
to do and they do so in advance of war
or genocide they portray that which they
are about to attack
as less than human as a diseased
or as vermin or something like this
and so i i just have the sense that it
is a
an unfortunate but natural human
tendency that has been dragged into
exactly the wrong
realm and that we are we are missing the
obvious question
which is are we closer
to a decent answer by
completing the american experiment by
fixing what isn't right and making
you know continuing in the same
direction or uninventing it and trying
over
and i think if you compare those two
things an honest analysis would tell you
there is no comparison yes there are
serious flaws and there is serious
unfairness but we
you know are far closer to having gotten
it right
than having gotten it so wrong there's
no hope for repair
so i i just can't believe we're about to
reverse
course rather than uh you know to
redouble our efforts in making this the
fair and wonderful place that it has
always aspired to be
well maybe we're in that uh deep valley
that you and i talked about with regards
to the uh
the adaptive landscape model and we're
jumping the discourse gap
and um we're finding ways to i mean look
i
the problem i have being a classical
liberal is that i think
liberalism at its core is the
willingness to hear other voices i may
not agree with them but the true liberal
welcomes the provocation and does not
retreat from it
um we want to come together and have
critical be more critical thinking
people
you know how can we how can we find
solutions rather than focus on the
problems
and intend to the problems and find
better solutions and get to the
the peaks how do we do we get to that
peak
whatever that peak is well i also think
something is missing
because even as you describe it there i
mean i know you and i are of like mind
about this and that we have
a parallel experience but i think people
have the sense
that talking to people who have a very
different perspective is like taking
your
medicine and the experience of actually
doing it is
totally the opposite right i actually
quite enjoy the conversations that i
have with people
who can explain to me how the political
landscape looks very different to them
or how the the scientific landscape
looks different
those conversations are very
rewarding and conversation with somebody
who shares your viewpoint
can be reassuring but it doesn't
broaden your understanding nearly so
much
and so i i really wish i could just let
people
in on not only the uh
the analytical experience but the the
feeling
that accompanies being able to cross
some big
gap that is famously supposed to be
unbridgeable and discovering a human
being that you actually like on the
other side
yeah and and learning something and
taking something away from the
conversation and growing and modifying
your belief system and
um reminds me of a poem i wrote called
grave matters all
judgments passed on others belonging the
court of self
take not a part of the blame accept not
projections of shame
blame pastor others is judgment passed
on
self to begin a sentence of revenge dig
two graves
eventually we all end up in the happy
ever afterwards of our emotional
hospitals
so you know how can we look to self and
in
you know the involution of self and to
evolve that
better sense of i don't know it all i'm
so i've said this to you before
like the more i learn the more i realize
i don't know
and that's stupefying it's like going
into the
finding the clearing in the lungs of the
forest and then realizing that
there's this massive expanse of
new forests ahead and new journeys and
trails to go on
that's opening up to possibilities and
what an adventure
i mean just glorious i i totally agree
with this
um that people in general they just seem
to have
at least what i feel is the inverse
reaction but the discovery
that there is a great deal you do not
know is
it's an invitation it's uh it means that
there is profit to be made that you were
unaware of
and so you should be happy at this
discovery because
who knows what you'll find out rather
than just constantly reassuring yourself
that
you've got it nailed and it's all uh
very simple and
the trick is just to force other people
to see it that can't be very fun
no we we have to have a bit of serious
play i mean it can be serious but we
have to have a good play
i mean a lot of my work in my career has
been improvised and in the moment and
off the cuff
and living on that phenomenological edge
the razor's edge
not just the bleeding edge or there's
too many edges in there
um but how we how we can add a little
artistry
and flavor and fun and
um maybe take a bit of dr carl young and
mix it up with dr zeus
and um present it in a way that that
isn't too
serious and uh and studious
we we do need the the serious and
studious and the the
legislative you know legalese etc etc
but
i think we you and i have talked about
how we came together
and how how much respect i have for you
and the work you do and the podcast that
you did with uh
your brother being one of the the the
best
uh podcast episodes i've ever heard on
the portal it was just so genuinely real
and authentic and you know the
brotherhood
of weinstein was on auditory display
yeah um yeah we uh it's funny
i i don't know when we first became
aware of each other i guess it's been uh
a year maybe two um but
but in any case yes there's an awful lot
of um
parallelism i think in our our
perspectives but
because of that i want to um unpack a
little bit here
i have the sense that in describing
who you are and what you do that the
real category that would be most
descriptive
just is not one it's a category that
doesn't exist
or at least if it does exist we don't
name it because it would be
uncomfortable
but i have the sense that you uh
you are restless
that you are of a certain age you've
accomplished
many of the things that you set out to
accomplish
and you're now eager to fix the world or
something like that
am i anywhere in the ballpark yeah
you're in the ballpark i think
eager to help the people who truly can
fix
i believe truly can fix the world
and you know
people that have uh
the courage and fortitude and the
decency
to um to go out there and try
and to galvanize support no decency
finds
no refuge in a juror's prudence of fear
we need courageous um
people from all different walks of life
to to help tend to the fabric of the
american personality
uh and and the constitution
and that beautiful document i remember
when i first read it
it was i was just stupefy that
these human beings came up with that
document
at that time and how astonishing
it still is to this day it lives on
yeah it's um it's a living testament to
their ideals even where they didn't meet
them
it's uh it's evidence of their
their blind spots i mean it's really a
marvelous
lesson in what the finest minds of a
particular era
could see and couldn't see and
i hear it described in such
bleak terms especially on the left i
mean it's
maybe spoken about overly rev reverently
on the right where it's treated as
almost a religious document
without flaw because it's divinely
inspired and on the left it's treated
like just a you know a series of errors
and the fact is
it's a prototype it's a prototype of
something absolutely marvelous and
you know what i was thinking about when
i asked you about
what it's like to have joined the us is
i'm
just recognizing how many people saw
brilliance
in our model and
adopted it sometimes formally and
sometimes less so
but you know the uk among the places
that uh
took up the mantle of american democracy
uh and have done it differently but
how marvelous is it that the colonists
spelled out a vision
so beautiful that it was
contagious and that it actually spread
freedom in its wake
yeah and i actually think right now in
in england britain
we could do with some of the uh the
tenants of the
constitution and the amendments because
hearing that there are now
hate crimes uh and
thought crimes are now part of the law
in england and the understanding of the
fundamental understanding of what
what free speech is and how we
must protect um and
fight to protect our our freedom to
speak our mind
however challenging
and his with certain people to hear them
um
you know we there is where is the line
you know that line is always it's always
a difficult conversation to have
you know about um abortion and
the the the line of freedom of speech
incitement to violence well what is
violence is our words violence i
remember
reminded of ricky gervais who said
offense isn't given it's only taken
you know if you choose to take offense
then take it um
i'm giving it right and it's not
tragic if you're offended the idea that
we're supposed to remake
civilization to avoid you being offended
uh that's a
that's a dire prescription right there
yeah and i think we what i've been doing
with the respondent and why i started
the respondent is to try and just
begin a conversation a multimedia
conversation
um and part of it came came about
through this
you know we talk about the fact the
founding fathers the the constitution
and america and where we are today
part of it came out of this toxic
masculinity
um smashed the patriarchy all men bad
and there were so many men being
canceled some of them
were you know justifiably tried in the
court of public opinion
and then um tried in the in the legal
system
but some i think were caught up
particularly in my business in the
entertainment industry
without uh due process and
you know trying to return a place where
chivalry i feel like chivalry is
is dead or it's um it's been lost i'm
reminded of her
i forget who wrote the quote but uh
but it goes but the mind of man is
not like fourier's heated body
continually settling down into an
ultimate quiet uniformity
the character of which we can already
predict
it is rather like a tree shooting out
branches
which adapt themselves to the new
aspects
of the sky towards which they climb and
routes which can tort themselves
among the strange strata of the earth
into which they delve
and when i think of that and i think of
congeniality and how to be a more gentle
man and the origins of chivalry which i
think
um they go back to it was a code of
conduct
i think developed in the 13th century
and the ideas of chivalry
and how to be more shilvaric
how can we even begin to have that
conversation
if we are meant the very idea of man
is extinct smash the patriarchy as i
understand it
the matriarch and the patriarch is the
mother figure and the father figure
and um what are we gonna do we're gonna
suggest
smashing the matriarch and toxic
feminine no that's just the shame rage
and the
point counterpoint and you know
most of us i think are most of us men i
would like to
think are um are not
uh looking to smash ourselves and
tell ourselves that we are all toxic
yeah uh well first of all i very much
liked that recitation i've never heard
it before but uh
it's it's brilliant the
issue of what is happening to
masculinity is
so dire and you know you say
that some people were tried in the
court of public opinion and then tried
in an actual court
and others were just tried in the court
of public opinion but even more
distressing than that is the fact that
some people were tried
in the court of public opinion for
things that aren't even wrong
yeah and it's guilty till proven more
guilty
not even guilty till we're even innocent
or innocent or proven guilty
and that is what really concerns
me particularly in the area of family
law
is one place um you know the respondent
deals with
with the familial bond the familial
tapestry of how we
collectively as a community and
interpersonally within our
marriages relationships um
father son mother daughter etc etc
how do we tend to that into
communication
skill interpersonal communication i
think most of us are vaguely familiar
with stories of uh family breakdown
or familial breakdown we have a friend
or a or a family member who endured a
bad breakup it's a common trope in our
dramatic
and comedic entertainment and real life
obviously reliable fodder for places uh
media outlets like tmz and supermarket
tabloids
when it comes to celebrity relationship
implosions in particular um
i think that there's there's this notion
this this
thought that men and particularly
celebrity men
and i don't classify myself in that
bucket
um are super human and
they're not we're not we're just human
beings and every individual is
struggling with something and as we are
trying to remain
physically
[Music]
physically uh healthy within the
organism
we have to remind ourselves to exercise
from the neck up
i think mental health is a huge huge um
issue right now it was particularly with
men we don't
because we don't talk about it um
you know particularly with covid and
this this messaging of
social distancing which i've mentioned
you before is
is so inherently flawed it should be
physical distancing and social
connectedness
we are human beings we're sentient
creatures we we
we should be encouraged to come together
as small groups and larger groups and
and in in and be communal and um
there's a lot of currently i've i've
seen a lot of commentary
on this topic of men
being bad and were bombarded by messages
about the deeply corrosive effects of
toxic masculinity
and confronted with institutions
psychologically conditioned now to think
masculinity
is toxic that men are bad uh
man's kindness is extinct chivalry is a
bygone notion
and particularly in the family law
system
it's rife with outdated gender ideas
every bit of sexist
as those faced by women in
other arenas past and present and we
need to spirit level the sexes somewhat
so uh i i very much like this topic i
have a lot of thoughts on it myself and
i believe
that the sexes are up for a
renegotiation
but that that renegotiation
would be insane to implement some kind
of um sameness
to enforce it in any way in other words
i believe
strongly that there are features of
masculinity
that are honorable and that we must
preserve
there are parallel features in the
feminine world
that we need to honor and preserve we
should leave people the freedom
to avail themselves of these things
irrespective of what sex they
are are born in but
we should not expect men to be
like women or vice versa we should find
out what people want when they're truly
liberated
you know in my case um my wife
is lovely but she does have a kind of
male bent she she plays like a boy and
the animus has risen within heather
yes and you know it's a great thing i i
i'm
very pleased to have a a partner to go
adventuring with
and somebody who doesn't shy away from
danger or pain or all of these things so
it's you know it's not like
uh it's not like i want to go back to
the 50s
right and sometimes that's how it's
portrayed at the same time
i think we are doing a tragic disservice
especially to our boys in telling them
that
masculinity is um
a hazard or is inherently bad or
something like this because among other
things
i may have said this to you already i i
can't remember but
the fact is straight women do not like
weak men and so if you induce
your boys to become weak you're setting
them up for
a tragic romantic failure
and this yeah and i agree with you and
you have said that to me uh
before and i i couldn't agree more that
how the the mother and father if we're
talking in in simple terms or the
matriarch and the patriarch negotiate
these differences of opinion
of parenting i think is is so that the
child gets the most opportunities to
take risks
but not risks that will kill or severely
injure
him in the case of boys because i'm a
man and i have boys
it's not sexist i'm not you know
not talking about girls and women for
that reason
um i think that's vital i remember the
first time my son squared off
to fight physically and i reassured my
wife at the time
that it was a necessary rite of passage
and as our youngest
i think he was six maybe at the time
and my eldest was eight there's a
two-year age gap
they needed that experience that
prideful moment
uh he needed the younger brother because
i've been the younger brother
of taking his elder brother on and maybe
even teaching him a lesson
in the process which he did a couple of
times
and she was still somewhat distressed as
i led the boys into the back garden or
backyard
and created this imaginary boxing ring
uh
although she did she trusted well trust
is important it's vital she trusted me
enough to
to calm her understandable mother bear
concerns
uh to believe that i might know maybe
better how to handle this rush of
testosterone situation and this sort of
balanced parenting
cannot take place if men and fathers
aren't present there must be a balanced
or renegotiation as
i say the spirit level of the sexes in
order for boys to become more fully
formed
self-actualized young men take those
rights of passage with a deeper more
imagined sense of healthy boundaries
so that they can eventually alone
take those steps to start to think
like men responsibility equals reward
and
feel like boys risk taking equals
ambition
and i think more we can advocate
fatherhood you know advocating
fatherhood is not about
admonishing or diminishing motherhood i
believe a
primary role of a father or one of the
primary roles is to maintain an
aura a presence if you will which says
look
and listen son life has problems
we're gonna solve that problem together
one day
um you'll have you'll have your
you'll leave home and and be playing
more seriously on your own
with your own little children
uh boys of your own maybe or friends
sons and daughters to play with
tend to be responsible for let's prepare
for that day
to learn how to confidently and sensibly
risk take together and i think it's
vital for boys to learn
through the eyes and the experience and
the behavior
reflected from a father and to learn
boundary setting
self-discipline um and how to instill a
sense of
empathy for themselves their partners
peers and friends
and eventually um you know their
ultimate partner
hopefully and when the testosterone in
boys is not channeled well
boys become destructive and when
father's not present in the family home
to instruct
boys destruct and when testosterone is
channeled well
boys become constructive so why
aren't we advocating why aren't we
talking about
positive masculinity and
positive father figures fathers role
models
more so that we can leave a legacy for
the
for the younger generations that we
leave behind
so i want to connect a couple threads if
i can manage to do it
um your your theme about the
constructive
aspect of masculinity is very important
and near and dear to my
heart and i have the sense
that we are very complex creatures i
mean that's
a fact and that what that means is that
the way things are hooked together
is often not obvious and so there's this
tendency
this uh chesterton's fence problem where
something
the purpose of which is not totally
obvious gets removed because a strong
argument can be made that it's somehow
antiquated and that very frequently we
are living
the harm that arises from having
eliminated something
vital without realizing we were doing it
and what i see
on this topic is that we have
renegotiated the rules of
sex and that those rules of sex
basically we are told that any
resistance to just
getting laid and not thinking about the
consequences
is somehow um oppressive
and that the discovery that sex is just
a biological drive and that you should
follow it where it leads you
and there's no reason to make it more
than it is and all of that there's no
reason even really to give a damn about
the person
that you're having sex with that the
consequences of this are many
and one of them is that it puts males
in one of two modes and it's not the one
that we should want
to flourish right men have always had
the opportunity
to spread their seed without taking
responsibility for the consequences
and that is not men at their best that's
men at their worst
and the problem the reason that we are
now hearing about toxic masculinity
is that in a world where men have been
told that that part of them is just fine
and they should
you know activate it is a world that is
dangerous
to women because the men are viewing
them as targets
rather than as partners and
in that world there's this temptation to
then write the rules that make
women safe to be around men rather than
writing rules in which men are
prone to behave more honorably because
frankly
it's the only path to a life worth
living
and i guess the final thing i would say
on this is that
in a world where sex had not been
demystified
and where it was therefore
difficult to come by and required real
investment by men in order to persuade
women to go to bed with them
men moved mountains in order to impress
the women
that they were most interested in and
that was a process that was
tremendously powerful and the fact that
these things
are now frequently satisfiable with a
kind of junk level of sex
is resulting i think in a great deal of
potential
just being absolutely squandered because
there's no motivation to follow it
well put very well put more well better
better well put than i could have uh
have talked about i you know i i i
interviewed uh
for the respondent later in the season
it reminds me of
uh um when i interview a family law uh
family law attorney
and she has an all-female practice and
only represents men
and she'd been she'd been
practicing law for many years in family
law and
saw the the bias within family law
courts and decided that she would
try harder to help men and when i found
out
that it's a felony for a father to
kidnap
his his child and it's not a felony for
a mother
to kidnap the child and by a felony i
mean
um the birth certificate
a mother can place on a birth
certificate uh any name she wants
not tell the biological father
and the biological father who may not
have any idea that he is a father
at all then has 30 days
to appeal and if if they
the father doesn't appeal then
that father will never know his son or
daughter
and more importantly or just as
importantly
that son or daughter will never know or
grow up as a child through you know to
maturation
through childhood not knowing their
biological father or mother now of
course there are cases where
there are uh men who we can say don't
deserve that
and probably women who don't deserve
that and
you know i've talked in at length about
nikki crick's study on
um the differences between character
traits and
between women and and men and the female
and the male
whereas men move faster to physical
um violence women
they they get past it men get past it
quicker and move on we
move to what she called reputation
savaging
and how we can find a place
where um where more
fathers and sons are connected less
families are
raised less children are growing up with
in single parent families
and we can understand that not all dads
are dead broke dads many of them are
dead beat dads many of them are dead
broke dads because
of the system and i think this is a
major
uh for me it's a it's a huge
huge area in our legal system that needs
reformation i'm i'm talking
later today with molly olsen who who was
she led the drive for
equal shared parenting or um default
shared parenting
in uh minnesota i believe there's three
states that have that
and that has fundamentally changed not
only the face of family law
it reduces obviously the attorney's
money there's less incentive for them to
be able to churn
but it also brings half of that family
when a child is erased or a father or a
mother is a raised
half of their extended family is gone
and are raised
too this can't be good for our
communal collective it cannot be good
and understandably we focus on you know
the immigration
issues at the border and the separation
of families
i wonder why we don't place more focus
or as much focus i should say on
our legal system and our families
who are being torn apart because of that
and our children
particularly our boys you and i have
talked about education and um
you know in the in the prison system and
in education
there were just so many areas that we
could really improve on i think
yes we uh have lost sight of the
essential
features of a functional society and we
now treat them as
aesthetic which is most unfortunate
so i it you know i think one has to look
at all of the the tropes the narrative
tropes
surrounding um
mayor you know children out of wedlock
right
so there's something very antiquated
about the idea that
children should only occur within a
marriage
and you know i think that we think this
is antiquated because the notion
was prior to the invention of reliable
birth control and so of course
reliable birth control made it possible
to have sex and not produce children and
therefore it meant sex could precede
marriage more frequently than it would
have in the past because
women of course are wired to fear
producing children without a partner
because of course
children are so expensive i don't mean
expensive financially but
so intensive to raise that a partner is
a necessary feature
right it is a much harder job to raise a
child alone
but at some level in the renegotiation
that occurred
we lost sight of the fact that actually
society
has an overriding interest
in making sure that children are well
raised
and that well-raised children are much
more likely in a household that has two
parents and part of the reason for that
is because that household has more than
two parents it has two extended families
and we don't frankly even know the
extent to which
having two parents is
a necessary way to learn how
the navigation of being human even
occurs
right to have two parents is to
guarantee that there will
be two people in your lives in your life
who
have distinct opinions on things
and then you as a child growing up in
that environment
will learn of the two perspectives and
you will have to figure out
how to weigh them in a single parent
household that is much less
likely and so i'm not telling you i know
the answer to this at all
but i am telling you that at least we
ought to be able to identify the value
and say
two-parent household is not really an
optional thing it's not aesthetic it's
functional
and just in the same way the state
sees it as it within its interest to
make sure that a child is well nourished
is mentally well nourished less
important
yeah no and i'm dismayed at the tenor of
much of the discussion that's taking
place about the nuclear family
marriage appears to my eyes to be the to
be on life support and i see
and uh read many um
many people who appear to be happy about
that even while a backbone narrative of
this pandemic
or panic democracy we're living through
involves families hunkered down in
quarantine
the statistics reveal a decay of
marriage as a foundational institution
as i write this the wall street
uh the wall street journal
um uh i think had
reported that u.s marriage the u.s
marriage rate had plunged
i think it was six point um 6.5 new
unions per 1 000
people according to the
national center for health statistics
the lowest level since the government
started keeping
scores since 1867. now of course
you know a plunging quantity
of marriages says nothing of quality
quality
is important you and i have talked about
you know equity and equity of outcome
and equity of opportunity
and one might argue that fewer good
marriages is better than a greater
number of bad ones but the
the trend speaks to i believe
the belief that we as a collective
think that marriage is a social
institution um
that leads to a better outcome for
children is
is not the case and when i when i read
i think it was david brooks celebrated
new york times writer
who recently wrote an article or an
essay
in the atlantic theorizing the nuclear
family is obsolete in fact it should
it was a bad idea and a mistake i think
is what he called it to begin with
really i mean and you mentioned the
1950s you know the
he i think he pointed to the image of
the 1950s the halcyon days of the dinner
table
families and we mythologize you know
it's actually
a fantasy that in reality was nothing
more
and than an anomalous
blip you'd i'm sure the the 50s
were wonderful and i'm not taking
anything away from the 50s but
our reimaginings of the stories from the
50s there were some
hard times it was a hard grind in the
50s
but how how can we better
tend to our younger generations i mean
i've talked about
the gen z's and millennials before and
you know i hear people that sound like
my grandparents oh you know
i remember i was a kid i wouldn't have
done that and you don't want to do this
and
we we as the older generation have to
accept responsibility that it's on us
it's not it's not fully on them they
weren't around when we were their age so
we
are responsible for what they're coping
with today
oh absolutely the dysfunction just
propagates through the ages
and you know this uh question about the
nuclear family and
is it an invention and all of these
things i find the conversation
just shockingly confused there i mean
there is a way in which the nuclear
family
is a recent invention but it's not by
virtue of it having
come about from whole cloth it's a
matter of
the economic realities having caused
people
to move away from their natal homes and
therefore families being reduced
to nuclear from a larger phenomenon
it's not that they were established from
a lesser phenomenon and that this
you know requirement that you bond with
somebody was imposed from above
now there are cultures where it doesn't
exist but in general
it doesn't exist by virtue of a failure
of certainty of paternity
so in places where a man
is unlikely to be certain that the
offspring produced by a woman
are actually his there's a phenomenon
called the mother's brother phenomenon
where uh men are better off investing in
their sister's children
who they know are related to them than
they are investing in the children that
are attributed to them
who may or may not be related to them
but that's
actually we know just evolutionarily the
result
of a failure of information a lack of
certainty
rather than it being some kind of
enlightened state
and so to the extent that
the rules informal or formal can result
in males being certain of who their
offspring are
when males are certain of who their
offspring are they invest because it's
the right thing to do
males have an interest in producing
offspring that are
viable and uh you know well adjusted and
two-parent household is is the easiest
way to get there
yeah very much so all of the statistics
show
that that a child a boy raised in
a two-parent family household is going
to have
a far greater chance of success in life
and be able to see
further into the future and the
possibilities and the probabilities
in every metric uh less likely to end up
in
in prison less likely to end up on drugs
less likely to take
their own life and all of these things
i think
where did we get to a place brett where
did we get to a place in our society
that the value of life has become
so
extinct people just so many people just
don't care
you hear about someone taking their life
and uh he deserved it she deserved it
well good riddance
really and
you know going back to man and fathers
those
those men and fathers haven't had
mothers
and sisters and daughters
we're all in this together
it just i've read the notes i've read
the suicide notes from the fathers
the good men you know not the bad men
the ones who just wanted to
you know run along and be the casanova
and procreate and then move along um
and that they're heartbreaking
you know i've talked to the men who have
have been at the edge
of life living on the edge of
existential
terror and angst you know trauma resides
in the body
and the body keeps the score to quote uh
bessel van der kulk's beautiful book
and how that inescapability
not just not just of a father removed
from
his children or son
or a son from father but for a veteran
who returns from war
and has ptsd and how we can
start to extend our presence further
i think that's really what one of my
goals is
to meet and innovate these through these
limits
and find a way to learn and lean into
learning and the portal of learning to
quote your
your brother's podcast the portal and
find ways to say
how can i give not what can i get from
this
yeah you know i was uh
heather and i were watching with our
older son uh the big short
last night and there's a very eloquent
speech in the end of it where the the
main character
the michael baum character is describing
the effect he saw of
wall street on the people who inhabit it
and that basically it turned them
inhuman
by virtue of putting them so closely in
contact with the functioning
of markets that it became
all of the stuff that's harder to defend
and harder to describe
falls away because the stuff you know
the
the balance sheet is so clear
and i think that there is something to
the idea that what has happened
is that markets which initially
facilitated the production
of value became
subtly empowered to commodify everything
even the things that should never have
been allowed
to have been commodified and that
this uh expendability that you describe
is really the consequence of that that
we
uh view everything you know the fact
that somebody
in order to figure out what to charge
you for insurance
or what to pay your relatives if you're
killed you know
assesses your value on the one hand
there's nothing wrong with that
calculation
on the other hand there's everything
wrong with that calculation right
i agree yeah it um
i remember reading uh joseph campbell's
book the hero with a thousand faces
and um soon after i read that book i
wrote a poem and the poem was a very
short poem
and it was about the year that were
i thought about gravestones and that
year that were born
and the year that we die you know i
think in uh perhaps it's the mexican
uh in the mexican culture it said we
have three deaths
and the one the first death is the
moment that we realize that we are
mortal
we fully face our mortality and that
second death
is the last breath we exhale if and when
we realize we're on our way out and the
third death
is the last time our name is mentioned
on earth
and i heard that
and i thought about the gravestone and
that dash
in between and how we dash
sometimes through life and how
we are so focused on the next moment
the next week um the next year
that we forget to remind ourselves
that the now moment is all we have um
and that dash of our life
the poem was called at prince's prayer
and it went it goes a prince's prayer
so i'm going to read it through my my
eyes a prince's prayer
1968 dash
question mark a prince's prayer
a thousand faces worn the dash between
the dead and born
i forget her to remember myself
forever and ever amen
and how
we can remember to that life is lived
forwards and remembered backwards
you know when i first started looking at
emotions and feelings and
emotional intelligence and behavioral
science and
all of that which i came to in my 40s
and then
started reading books at 45 when all i'd
read was scripts and wasn't encouraged
to read when i was a kid my
my wonderlust for literature
and how i say to anyone who listens
surround yourself with books even if you
do not read them and ever pick them up
it's so important that we honor and
remember the great corpus of
of literary works many of which i'll
never have the time to read
unfortunately and how
how we can better tend to self capital s
because the better i ask myself a
question once
i think i mentioned it to you the other
day well i didn't know anything about
philosophy and i sat down and i wrote
who am i in my iphone and i ended up
with 11
1164 notes a few hours later it was
astonishing just kept going deeper into
the dialectical dive
and then i started asking the meaningful
answer the meaningful question so the
first one i went to with that was
if love is the answer what is the
question
[Music]
and my simple first place that i arrived
at
the answer that i found to the
meaningful
question asked of the meaningful answer
was
back to socrates know thyself first aid
thyself
for if thy knows thyself better
then one can love oneself
more deeply in becoming
more known and then love another
more deeply capital o and i think that
space is where i like to
live reside remind myself to be in the
now moments
you know the now and then
i remind myself but then
i'm back again in the now moment and
feelings and
emotions when i when i started exploring
that you know
what's the simple way of ex of
explaining what an emotion and a feeling
is well for me
an emotion is a feeling with a memory
attached
and how say we we go to work
and our boss comes over and is what are
you doing you're late on that report and
we might get
you know to use one of the work current
phrases triggered
and it's not that in that in that moment
an emotion is coming up but based on the
feeling with the memory attached
maybe when we were six or seven years
old and we were yelled at or
admonished by a parent for not tying our
shoelaces quickly or we were going to
later get
we were going to be late to get on the
bus to go to school or to an outing or
whatever
and just understanding how the organism
that's where i'd
love to dive into i've been studying a
little effect theory and
what the organism what the body is
trying to tell me and i pay attention to
that
you know and that allows me to be less
reactive and more responsible which is
one of the things that the respondent is
all about
well that's fascinating i i should say
i have long had this little
puzzle in my mind i'm often more
comfortable with people
who are unflinching in
their willingness to engage the question
of
their own death that somehow
i i feel like we are moving in the wrong
direction on this and we treat
death as a failure you know
it is an inevitability it is not a
failure now it can be a failure if it
happens too soon
but there's something you know in fact i
was thinking about this as i was biking
through a cemetery the other day
and i encountered one of these
situations where there was a husband and
wife's grave and one of the partners was
gone and the other was not yet gone but
that means that the partner who isn't
gone
knows exactly where they're headed right
they they have a relationship with their
own grave
that most don't and um
you know it's not that i think there's
such
marvelous value in pondering
death itself because there's nothing to
it but
there is something to recognizing
the implications of the finiteness of
life
and in some ways the arbitrariness of
death
you know just the fact that um i don't
know i must say of all the philosophical
puzzles i am
most troubled by
the fact that in many cases you don't go
get to know the end of your own story
you know john f kennedy does not know
the end of his story we all
synonymize him with the end of his story
but
presumably he knew nothing about it and
there's something about that that is a
little hard for me to accept
but um i don't know
it it's it makes me think of you know
sometimes i get into word play so i'll
take words like
depressed and like that's deep rest
sometimes the psychological needs a deep
rest i think
about together to get her
um what other words do i have i'm
reminded of a caymus quote i think it
was camus
the philosopher who said we value our
own lives in spite of our mortality
and in spite of the universe's silence
while we can live with a dualism
i can accept periods of unhappiness
because i know
i'll also experience happiness to calm
we cannot live with the paradox
which is i think my life is of great
importance but i also think it's
meaningless
and i think that crisis we you and i
have talked before about
sense making and meaning making and um
meaning seeking and i think
i do think we have a crisis of
perhaps a crisis of meaning but crisis
of faith one i
mentioned to you the other day my
definition of meaning is
everything happens for a reason we make
up afterwards
i love this because i
use everything happens for a reason as
an example
of a literally false metaphorically true
statement because of course it's
nonsense that everything happens for a
reason
but a person who is convinced that
everything happens for a reason will
very frequently find opportunity in
tragedy for example
that somebody who wasn't convinced of
this would miss
so by adding that last piece that we
make up the reason
uh afterward uh you complete the circle
perfectly you imply the same thing much
more
poetically which looks like that comic
menu karma has no menu you get serve
what you deserve
[Music]
i've never heard that um but i also
am intrigued by your obvious
relationship with poetry
which i must say i have a relationship
with poetry i
rarely meet anyone else who does my
phd advisor did and we always got along
quite well in part because i think we
had the same appreciation for it as a
tool
i think to many people for one thing i
would say i have no patience for free
verse
that it seems to take the value of
poetry and to me it just seems to throw
it out the window
is that right i was going to invite you
to do an improvised poem with me live on
air right now
oh well i'm going to politely decline
but but my sense is that a proper
constraint
forces you to explore language in the
neighborhood of the concept you're
trying to convey
but in order to get the meter right and
to get the rhyme right
you have to search farther afield and so
you very frequently discover things that
are true about some concept that's
important to you
that you wouldn't have gotten to if you
could just use prose so
to me free verse has the same kind of
uh let's put it this way there is good
free verse but a lot of it isn't good
it's too much license and not enough
constraint as far as i'm concerned
um of course well i have i i have uh
having not been schooled in poetry and
come to poetry
gosh i think i wrote my first what i
would consider poem before i published
uh
my poetry book the new ledge k n e w l e
d g a
d g e um last year
uh i you know iambic pentameter i heard
about at school but it was a distant
memory to me
so i i guess i break all the rules in
terms of poetry
um and will i don't know their poems or
or quotes
i wrote one called the calamity of
conscience and it goes
the cerebral paradox the elusive
obvious the letting go of holding on
finding by not looking unearthing
without
disturbing the ground going to pieces
without falling apart
accepting answers without question
unconscious incompetence conscious
incompetence conscious competence
unconscious competence a little bit of
masra i think was maslow's hierarchy of
uh needs yeah at the end there
um so i'm always i'm always you know
testing the boundaries and
well let me let me be very clear first
of all the thing about the rules
is knowing how to break them i'm all for
breaking the rules
but i'm not for breaking the rules just
to break them
how can you break the rules if you don't
know them though well that's
well for one thing i wouldn't call what
you have just
recited here free verse now maybe
technically it is
but the thing is there's some and in
fact maybe we should get to the code at
some point but
you clearly have some kind of a highly
regimented linguistic code and maybe it
surrounds
more meaning than it does meter and
rhyme
so maybe you're free verse with respect
to meter and rhyme
but what you're saying is it's
constructed
in my opinion to be
spoken and to have
meaning and emotion imbued into it the
way a pianist
can imbue a piece with emotion by the
way they play
and you actually can see it in sort of
the physical
interaction with the piano so anyway i
um it's possible that my category is too
narrow but my sense is
you are engaging a kind of uh regimented
requirement for your poetry at least
according to what you've said here
that uh is not troubling to me in the
slightest i quite like it
why thank you um i yeah
the expression i think it's it's
emotional expression
and how we can vocalize the poetry and
and the performance and who is
performing it what's the stage
um perhaps you we i don't know
on the dark horse podcast if if uh we've
if you've talked with
talked about poetry before who knows um
i don't profess to be an expert
and i think that sometimes when you read
it on the page
you can create and craft meaning making
in the moment
and the interpretation of what it means
to you what a quote or what a line
means to someone sometimes i play with
words you know i remember doing a whole
um equation uh set of quotes that were
literally
um written like mathematical formulas
uh like uh secrets plus silence plus
judgment equals shame love equals
empathy minus shame divided by the group
privacy yes versus secrets no and
the pain equation and um so i think
there is value in in both
in in being able to speak them
aloud even just to yourself i mean
really it's the it's the inner
it's the inner dialogue isn't it at the
end of the day brad that we're all in a
conversation with no one can really know
us
fully because that inner critic or that
inner champion
that's who we really need to get to know
um
and for me you know it's
i did it through well not i did it
i started to break through beyond my
pre-existing belief system
that night when i sat down and asked
that question who am i
and and then i think after that i wrote
the poem
uh the memory shelf which if will you
indulge me for one
one moment okay so
the memory shelf goes like this i have
recently become acquainted with myself
placed all my thoughts and memories
upon a memory shelf deep sea
diving into recesses of reese
peace by painful peace seeking
peace to unpack what's underneath
to see what's submerged and what comes
up to the surface
delving deep into the oceans of my mind
riding waves of
length discovering a mental health
a treasured wealth a salvage mission for
myself
to get connected with my own authentic
self
to tune into the memories upon my memory
shelf
this changeful self-reflection was a
choice though painful it has helped me
find my
true authentic voice i came to realize
through real eyes the real lies of my
past
and though the sea was vast i worked
them out at longest last
all my life i presented and what i
represented i resented put the kettle on
i'll make a brew of discontented
awaken you to stew on how to get through
when there's no way around you've got to
get into it to get over it to get
through it
when you can't bear it share it if you
can't control it let it go
when you can't feel it have faith that
exists when you can't hold on
release into the abyss and when you find
yourself fighting for your life
surrender for you have already found
yourself
inside the thoughts and memories upon
your memory shelf
wow that's fantastic i love you enjoyed
it
um yeah and it uh there's something
i wonder i it's a little hard to run the
experiment now
but i would love to know what it looks
like on the page without you delivering
it because there's an awful lot encoded
in the cadences in that
yeah i think uh well it's it i'm happy i
will send you a
a copy of the new ledge and um
you know you can you can get to know me
a little more through through the poetry
i think
the poetry led me to the philosophical
and the pocket oracle of
kind of self-help philosophical quote
book
um that was interesting to write to come
up with simple
lines and quotes that
had meaning to me at least
you know i think the first quote is
everything eventually connects
i've got the book here
ignorance is bliss until your life falls
apart
faith and belief can be a most dogged
pool bearer
tomorrow i vow to make better mistakes
[Laughter]
now and then wish upon and then realize
i'm now longer
zen um you know there's there's a ton in
there but i i've just
i've just immersed myself in this
learning space
and i think as an artist um i'm
constantly trying to
find new ways to to um to express
you know emotion and that's energy and
motion that's what i think emotion is
really
yeah you do this thing i've now heard
you do it several times here where you
um find i i assume that these are
false etymologies but they're full of
meaning
am i right about that that you are false
the false etymology when you what do you
mean by the false etymology
uh i assume that the word together is
not born of the concept of to get her
right and that and then sometimes i do
the the
the counter to that which is when i
studied for
studied when i started learning about
philosophy
philo sophia and philo being the
devotion and sophia being
wisdom or love so it's that devotion to
wisdom devotion to love you and i
talked very briefly about andrew yang
and
when he mentioned uh he tweeted during
his run that he thought that the
philosophers should be returned to the
white house i
cheered i fell off my charm like we need
the great intellectual minds of our time
the heterodox thinkers
the people who will question the
commonly held beliefs that used to back
in the day
be in the market square and the elders
and the young young
youngsters used to go and seek out and
the politicians seek out their wisdom
and opinion and becoming older is
inevitable but becoming an elder is a
skill
yeah it is a skill and in general
um we are failing to produce adults
that people are trapped in a kind of
permanent
adolescence and the only people
that we can trust to govern in such
complex
and perplexing times are
the few who have figured out how to
navigate these difficult things we need
philosophers
we don't need exclusively philosophers
but we need
at least a commitment to philosophical
rigor to be part of that conversation
well how do we i know we there's the
articles of unity
and uh we can
all of his help help move that movement
forward
you and i had talked about andrew yang
and the the
the potential free andrew yang hashtag
um
because i just think he's a tremendous
individual with a ton
of political potential that's unrealized
and i don't think it's going to be
realized
with the current dnc and how it's played
out and their choice
uh which seemed to me to be pre-ordained
beforehand and um the uh
the vp peg seems to be at least
to my mind pre-ordained beforehand and
there is i have a fear
that um that eventually at some point
during
that first term if indeed that happens
to be the case and
uh and joe biden wins that he will step
down and again these are projections
and i have no um
no for a fact it's just based on
everything that i've
seen and witnessed there was there is a
really disturbing
dystopia at play where the power mongers
at the top
are purporting to be the ones who are
the champions of the people at the
bottom in fact
they're doing the quite the opposite in
in closed
rooms and in private oh i agree and i
think there's already an agreement
for biden to step down and that the dnc
is
hoping we won't notice what they're up
to which of course is
an absolutely frightening transition in
the way governance
works even as dysfunctional as it's been
this is a new level of dysfunction
so how is a question and on
one level the answer is so obvious
and i think those of us if you see
as i alluded to before each
candidate has an iron-clad argument
for their election and that is the
unacceptability of the other
and they are both right and for
anybody if you see only one of their
arguments and the other one is in your
blind spot
then you will say oh well the answer to
what we have to do is simply clear
right you will say either we can't allow
biden to drag this woke insanity
into the white house because that will
destroy america and that's
true on the other hand we cannot allow
donald trump to politicize us into
oblivion
both of these things are un-american and
not decent and
too dangerous to even contemplate so
at the point that you see both sides
and not just the one you understand that
each one is unacceptable and the answer
is well
what would we have to do in order to not
elect either of them and the answer is
all you have to do is believe that it's
possible and what makes it possible is a
lot of people believing that it's
possible so
how about we have that conversation of
belief now
we learn that as we've been taught by
2020 so many times already and we're
only halfway through
the impossible is just around the corner
so
if we can just simply talk ourselves
into saying well
the two major parties forced us into
this
they gave us non-viable options which
requires us to ask
what else can we do we have to do
something else and
it is simply it is ours
to take back the white house and from
there
to restore the republic to functionality
we've run off the end of the tape
and it is time i agree
and there is
uh there is an urgency i mean i talk
about the tyranny of the urgent
that um you know i think about the
articles of unity we lack
we currently lack consensus
even about matters of basic fact
scientific facts scientists
are being cancelled and
losing their
jobs livelihoods i mean i don't need to
tell you
of all people about that and the current
tools
of our collective sense making are
seemingly
unable to close this gap
yes this
brink of economic catastrophe that we
have seemingly been teetering on for
quite some time now
um you know we did the
the how how our manufacturing base
and our reliance on um
we could talk about even corporate
america has gone woke
hollywood's gone woke and it's like a
work will go broke like
what did we get do we get everything
every
every app every screen i turn on it's
just
everywhere so
how how can we how can we galvanize this
how can we how can more people because
the big the two big
voices on either side have control of
the mainstream media and
the newspapers the broadcasting media
and
um it seems to be
about the ratings and the money and the
commoditization
of our values well i mean i think you're
you're asking the right question and in
some sense i don't believe
that corporate america has gone woke i
believe it is
doing what is expedient which is to say
it will broadcast the woke
message in order not to be canceled and
to get back to business as quickly as
possible
and so i think people have not
understood
what a large fraction of those who claim
to believe this stuff
is actually accounted for by the same
mechanism people solving their own
personal fears addressing them
by espousing beliefs that they don't
hold and then they will convince
themselves that they do hold them so
they don't have to explain to themselves
why they lied but once you realize that
this is a fringe
and really a very tiny fringe that's
bossing around
giant corporations um individuals that
are shaping society according to
something that we have no idea how many
people actually
believe it then the answer is well
people are solving their own problems
and that looks like
them saying what they don't believe out
of cowardice
what does the opposite look like well it
looks like
taking a risk to say what you do believe
in spite of the fact
that you may come out behind rather than
ahead for doing so
and i think you know this is a small
example
but you and i both believe that the
two major parties have delivered
outcomes that are so unacceptable that
we have to
uh consider things like the unity 2020
proposal
and we actually take a risk in so saying
by saying that we are actually risking
looking foolish we are risking being
blamed for some outcome
either of which will be terrible and i
think the point is well
people who have preceded us have given
up
far more to protect the nation this is a
small price to pay
and it can be distributed if more people
join
the clearer it will be that actually we
do have an opportunity to do something
outside of the script
and really at some level if you get it
you don't have much of a choice we have
been delivered unacceptable options
the cost will fall heaviest on
the young who have longer to live in its
shadow
it will fall heaviest on those who are
oppressed and therefore not in a
position
to protect themselves financially from
what's coming
so uh everything
that we hold dear
and just a simple fact of compassion for
those who are vulnerable
seems to require us to demand something
different and it's time for people to
stand up i agree
and i hope more more and more people
uh find their voice and their clarity
and join together and um
you know and and aren't too afraid of
being told
you know uh well if you if you if you go
down this path
then you're going to elect this person
again
um get behind this person because that's
the only
well one of the beautiful things about
america is everyone gets
everyone above a certain age and meets
the requirements gets to vote
so vote for whoever you would want to
vote for
and if you silence p i think this
happened in england with brexit
and i think we saw a large portion of
that in in 2016 with with president
trump
is when you tell half of the population
or nearly half of the population that
they are wrong and their voice doesn't
matter
um that they are all to use the
the terminology recently which i don't
like using but
you know neo-nazis or white supremacists
or they're all just they're all bad
people or they're crazy because they
believe in god or
um that their opinion doesn't matter
they're gonna they're gonna speak their
mind in the ballot box
when they when they pull that little
curtain which in england is usually when
you're gonna
pull a little curtain you tick the box
and so it's it's no surprise that
jeremy corbyn lost in england and brexit
was
i know there are many more factors to it
it's obviously not that simple
but um you know we're we're
we're a huge nation of
very diverse people and
we have great strengths and
um i i seriously believe that you know
someone said to me when i think i'd
retweeted you one day
uh recently about the uh lesser evil and
the animation
when someone wrote oh yeah been tried
before being trump and i remember one of
i remember sitting in school
my history teacher telling me about one
of the kings in england was about to
fight a battle and he saw a spider
and the spider kept trying to spin a web
and it kept
and this king had fought 13 sieges and
he or something like that and he
couldn't
find a way to win the battle and finally
as he was just mentally exhausted with
trying to find a way to rally his troops
and strategize how we would win this
particular siege in battle
the spider spun the web and that's where
the phrase if at first you don't
succeed try try try again
and just because it may have in a
different formula been tried before
that is the reason
why we must try again and
try in a different way and like you talk
about the ticket rather than the third
party
you know the ticket right now is is free
there is in fact the rewards to but
to purchasing or buying a ticket which
you don't have to because it's free
is you get you get to
have a seat at a new table and
a new conversation that doesn't exclude
either side that's inclusive and where
i'm at
having just you know done a live stream
inviting antifa and the proud boys on
is i want those extremes i think we
should be bringing those extremes of
society all the perceived extremes
together
to have the difficult challenging
conversations to hold that space to
listen with curiosity
and mediate through our differences and
bring those experts
in who who know way better than i
on how to moderate and mediate
through those conversations and if only
if only for the fact that one side feels
like they've been heard
for a few seconds then that's that
behavioral
barometer if you will may have been just
tended and tempered a little and i think
that it all starts with
the self and we can keep you know the
waveform if you will the movement
the patterns the frequency the
harmonious nature of how we can
share a little goodness a little
positivity and move from
hateful to grateful and from striving to
thriving
now it makes perfect sense and the fact
is
there's no guarantee but in a moment
where it is
obvious it could be obvious to everyone
that the country is on the verge of
tearing itself apart
it seems to me that our patriotic
obligation
is unity and that the only position that
will feel good in the aftermath no
matter what comes succeed or fail
is to have tried anybody who didn't try
in this moment who couldn't
muster enough imagination to see a
different possibility
despite the fact that the major parties
announced that they were unwilling to
lead
anybody who can't figure it out now wow
i mean
i just i have a hopeless feeling about
what that must be like and i would say
everyone else
it's time to to wake up and get to work
yeah i agree and i think that answers
the why
question and he who has a why can bear
anyhow
so the how gets answered after the the
why i think that was roomy
so you know answer the why um
do not question the why just answer the
why
for why is the answer and if we can find
a way
to come together and um
really galvanize uh
what you're doing just even the word
unity i mean come on
don't we all want a little more unity
and unification
it just feels good to even think in that
framework at this moment it's it's
liberating to do it
and i must say i i like your formulation
about um
that you should answer the why and the
how will follow that's really how things
work
the why motivates the how if you start
with the how
uh you may well spin your wheels
yeah it reminds me i think it was simon
sennick i think his name is he did a
great
presentation on business uh and um
how how the why needs to be answered i
think it was before
the how and the rest of it and many
companies start from the out the
concentric circles out it
did to the middle rather than the other
way around and um
apple is a a great example of that um
you know making making a difference we
believe we can make a difference
we believe we can create products that
will change lives and i think
unity 2020 has already started
to shift perspectives and perceptions
in the court and family homes of public
opinion
and as it settles in more and people
see more um spoken word
written text animation uh the signaling
uh the virtuous signaling not the virtue
signaling
of what people are really coming
together to do because it takes a
tremendous amount of people a tremendous
amount of effort
i don't know how you're doing it i don't
know
how many people are involved if you need
my help in any way i'm happy to help
um i think more people should come
together
uh to help this um to
to try to try to to find the how
once we've answered the why and uh
your conviction is clear and we will
call on you
sooner than you know so before we close
this out
um is there anything that we should have
talked about that we've
missed i i take this to be the first of
a number of conversations but
is there anything that belongs here that
we haven't gotten to
i think i should probably mention uh it
would be remiss of me not to mention my
uh
my book the respondent um
uh you know it's it sounds it sounds
trite but because
maybe it's time for rather than men too
maybe we need man 2.0 after all these
messages of all men bad
toxic masculinity and smash the
patriarchy
uh you know so so my book the respondent
which um is uh out on thanksgiving i
chose thanks
i launched the respondent video and
podcast series
on father's day because that day is
important
to honor and my publishers
and management company agencies said
that i was insane to pick
thanksgiving because it wouldn't be done
in time but that day of all days in
america is the day where we come
together
as families and give thanks and uh
gratitude
so that uh that that the first season of
the respond
the last episode will air on sunday 22nd
of november and then the book will
will uh will be out on the 23rd and um
yeah it's every two weeks at one o'clock
every other sunday bi-weekly
[Music]
and uh also the the voices in my head
event
i should mention that that's coming up
on this this saturday actually
um there are two actually two events one
at 12 o'clock
and that is the gamers gateway clancy
brown and i will be
clancy brown who's done multiple video
games and is the voice of mr krabs from
spongebob squarepants
and uh hank i think it's hank anderson
from this big video game
called uh detroit being
human i think it is and and i do this
character called colin from dragon age
we got caught up in a little bit of a
twitter mobbing
because we supported iron hershey lee
and jk rowling and because of their
views and what they had said and
so the first event is is to discuss that
that's um
that's a respondent special event really
a social impact
uh coming together with the fans and
fandom and then the one o'clock event
is the voices in my head which is my
other podcast the long-form conversation
for voices
and character voices and show writers
and showners behind some of your
favorite characters on
television cartoons and animation and
video games in voiceover
and that's called the voices in my head
jamboree fundraiser
um i have people like we have clancy
brown and i are hosting that we have tom
kenny who's the voice of spongebob
squarepants rob paulson who's the voice
of
pinky from pinky in the brain we had the
voice of batman
spiderman um so many great wonderful
animation and cartoon character voices
coming together
to um to have a jamboree event
live simulcast uh 1pm pacific time after
the gamers gateway event at 12 o'clock
and um yeah i think it's it's it's a few
dollars
and all of the money raised is going to
be donated to ayan hershey ali's aha
foundation
um she's a wonderful woman uh and her
journey and her story is truly inspiring
and profound
and um yeah we're gonna have some fun
we're gonna have a few special guests uh
andrea romano eight-time award winner
and lifetime annie award
achievement winner uh casting director
and
voice director and it's kind of a big
kick-off event
to a series of the voices in my head
events i think
covid and lockdown and having to
physically distance brett has been very
challenging for so many people
and the fans of video games and cartoons
would come together once a year for
an event called comic-con so i think
what we're going to do with the voices
in my head
is have a regular event where we can
focus on a particular area
of the entertainment business in
cartoons
video games and animation and have
you know owners of big video game
companies and talk about how to create a
video game
and how to run a video game company and
then have casting directors and
voice directors and then maybe branch
out from there so
long-winded answer um that's
that's the uh the the short term on
on the events for saturday and the big
big event
is the respondent on august 16th where
i i speak to and have on as my special
guest an evolutionary
biologist by the name of brett weinstein
uh well excellent i'm certainly looking
forward to that
so okay we've got the respondent the
book will be out on thanksgiving
i have to say i also hold thanksgiving
in special regard because it's the one
holiday that hasn't been
successfully commodified yet so it's a
great choice
um i i must say i'm a little disturbed
buried in what you said is the
implication that
uh the character of spongebob
squarepants
is not voiced by an actual sponge which
i
assume is some kind of species
appropriation
i won't let you down uh i remember
taking my son
my eldest boy charlie to the to
nickelodeon studios when they were
recording and he was six at the time
and all of the cast were in the booth
and and he looked up at the video
that was playing he looked up at ty he
looked in the studio tom kenny and
clancy brown
and all of the other actors he just
couldn't and then tom kenney came out
and did the voice
and he couldn't quite make the
connection but it is one of the joys of
of being in uh in the entertainment
business and and the gift of being able
to do
these cartoons is i remember going on
field trips there was some of my
greatest moments uh with my
with both my boys when they were in
prison in kindergarten
in first second third grade was going on
those school field trips sitting at the
back of the bus and then saying okay who
do you want to speak to today and they'd
go ben 10
or spider-man or um then it was
spongebob and just picking up the phone
and passing it around and them having
a conversation so yes simple answer
brett
um spongebob is not a sponge he's
not a spanish mr krabs is not an actual
crustacean wow that is uh
behind the voice it's an invitation to
cancellation if
if anything is well you're welcome to
come and join the event and we'll be
doing an improv
live flow with uh bringing all the
all of those characters together in one
kind of
virtual improvised cartoon performance
in place and get to see the people
behind you know the faces
and they're truly i can't tell you the
community of voiceover cartoon animation
voiceover is very special
um there is something very connective
about our community and how
brilliantly genius these these voice
actors are
and we don't know most people don't know
their names they know their voices
and um their their
their cartoon faces or animated faces so
i'm excited about that event
well that's an undeniably cool setup
i bet it it's great and uh anyway is it
is it recorded i i think it's going to
be recorded yeah i think it will go out
live stream
on uh it's hosted i think by thinkspot
and facebook will will live stream on
facebook and twitter and youtube
and there's this new platform i i don't
really know i'm a little old
long in the tooth but um called twitch
which is a video game platform so
apparently the voices in my head being
uh an animated cartoon
video game show and we have 13 episodes
actually 17
i've done three video episodes um that's
good
a good platform to have it on there so
it's going to be on there as well
cool available in multiple venues
yes all right well greg ellis it's been
a real pleasure
um so people can find you on the
respondent on youtube
um they can find you your
real greg ellis on twitter yeah they can
find me real greg alice on twitter real
gregellis.com is my official website
where
much of my special content lives and
thinksbot.com
greg ellis as well um and
uh yeah and instagram the usual
platforms of social
media and i'll try and not say
anti-social media
yeah that would be appropriate for sure
all right well thanks so much and
for all of you listening at home or in
your cars or jogging around thanks for
joining us
and we will see you next time thank you
very much brett it's been an absolute
[Music]
pleasure
[Music]
you